[Music]
do your part news submitted by concrete
roses brazil's president suggested that
we should all poop less to save the
planet
oh great I believe yeah that's it man
he's my president too wait how many
times are people poop in the day you
should be pooping multiple times a day
that's good for your gut but in your dad
you're not environmentalist I'd rather
be constipated you're eating a
plant-based diet and pooping in your
poop is pretty Maya biodegradable boobs
good for the environment no I didn't
think I thought yours was poop once a
day so they're saying that a healthy
pooping range a healthy pooping range
according to a 2018 study is anywhere
from three a day to three a week three a
week week I know - I have two
girlfriends that kid like that because
what they're really saying is a healthy
range is 3 to 2100 fiber what the [ __ ]
that's a huge range a giant wave like 3
times a week and it's so healthy
according to this mm-hmm
also track my [ __ ] a healthy way to eat
is one 255 meals a week yeah I mean I
guess as long as it's still coming out
who did the study a dietician or like
just some random person when people
can't [ __ ] every day it like blows my
mind US National Library of Medicine
National Institutes of Health there that
sounds made up that's where it was
published it was a national library of
national and medicine of Health /
capoeira the government site anyway so
the Brazilian President because Brazil
yeah I didn't know was that it how did
this fly get in here I know there's
something about knowing all right so if
you was saying that in order to help the
environment so I said it seems he said
quote it's enough to eat a little less
you talk about in
her mental pollution it's enough to poop
every other day that will be better for
the whole world huh not better fury you
don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] yeah you know
it's um you know it's interesting too so
this dude this president he shits a lot
no he's like 200 years old because he's
never shits so they're saying that last
month over two thousand two hundred and
fifty four square kilometers which is
about 870 square miles of the rainforest
we're top down in Brazil which is up two
hundred and seventy eight percent from
July of last year I was chopping so much
[ __ ] down cuz now he is the president
and he likes money so he has made a
number of anti-environmental statements
during his campaign and so now he
appears to be following through on those
statements in government so he's saying
[ __ ] last so we could cut more
rainforests very much yeah
so he's the one like he's literally
contributing to this but he's telling us
to [ __ ] and eat less yeah but also the
girls are big booties in Brazil so it's
like when you have bigger booty put more
yeah maybe the poops are bigger either
but he looks like he used to [ __ ] a
little more constipation from being on
the toilet smart joke was really funny
how they poop more in Brazil cuz their
classes are big and he's like and he's
like I know the poop comes out flatter
like roll up cuz their asses are fat in
it together
there's caca smears on the cheese yeah
no I mean like when you have to wipe it
yep turd like do the Wow I really like
this ah did you know that the largest
population of Japanese people outside of
Japan is in Brazil yeah I did not have
done everybody knew that really I bet
that probably good Japanese do this oh
yeah I heard you get bomb up and take
Japanese foods oh yeah but you see that
everyone this guy was making a joke
let's go okay let's go to him now joke
that that was pretty funny too sorry I'm
sorry
and he looks like he what was it you use
a patient face Oh
true yeah you had to be there Wow it was
pretty fun though you know we had a good
yeah we have two great jokes so the
audience can decide which one was better
in the comments tell me right now well
that's why I wanted to make sure in
highlight bars because I know the editor
had to choose one what I'm saying yeah
put them both up don't [ __ ] exactly
yeah yeah it's funny because that side
of the room was laughing at that and in
this side you had here I think I tried
to tune you out and then you know what's
happening I'm like no no no no no I have
tonight people need to hear this thank
you how much are the two million I'm
sorry baby you like Tai Chi like after a
while like it'd just be kind of blend
into the better the real question is
what kind of a dumb [ __ ] president
[Music]
but I could say that because I I know
that people in Brazil don't like the
president mmm if he's the same guy so
you're like a Brazilian Trump yeah over
the world right now but Trump has some
supporters this guy hasn't known oh
we're just like that we've been how'd he
get it was he put it was the aggression
Crips okay
corruption I made that part of I have no
[ __ ] clue yeah yeah probably yeah you
know I just I don't know I for some
reason I think anywhere south of Mexico
is all corrupt they speak Portuguese in
Brazil I have to see a map in my my head
I'm like yeah that's for this room I
read this article about how Latin
America can they have a lot of resources
there
everything to be a world power in these
countries can really like like playing
yeah they could thrive but the only
thing that's kind of stopping or the big
thing that's stopping is corruption in
their politics because they have a lot
of resources a lot of like natural
resources and [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm
probably so much money from tourism to
that like yeah I don't see any of but
they're also like uh new countries so
they're not like they're like they're
like new independent countries compared
to like I don't know like England or
something like that so they're still
like kind of getting things together
yeah like a cube we just opened up for
electorial in this [ __ ] yeah that's
crazy man I've been seeing all these
[ __ ] Instagram like peoples just
posting in Cuba and I'm like man that's
not yeah when it's interesting you went
I went I went a few a communist we're
here let me tell you something I went
before I opened up to United States
happy with Shias family so I was in
Canada with them and then flew to Canada
into Cuba they gave me like a couple
minutes extra questioning at the
American passport yeah with an American
pastor like you're not white [ __ ] you
yeah it's cold it's cold there I can get
but like no like like going to Cuba and
if you're like a white person with an
American passport they might treat you
differently and I feel you I feel you
and it's interesting it's it's weird
because you can you can feel that it's
definitely more old-school we shoot
other shoes other cars super yeah that's
like their thing you know and plus and
it's something about the weather down
there that because it's the all the
paint on the classic cars is the same
like they don't have to like repainted
yeah like it doesn't there's no like
real like wear and tear on the page
about the weather down there it's not
rusty and [ __ ] even though it's all
around the oceans yeah and it's like
near the equator that's so interesting
isn't that weird like I forget the
humidity kills calm yes same yeah I
forgot the signs behind it but they're
like yeah these are like this is his
house so it's like a time capsule didn't
like the 1950s or whatever where people
always dancing on the streets no one was
dancing in a street when I think a cube
I think people just dancing
smoking cigarettes big cigars colorful
buildings and smoking cigarettes yeah if
I can Ricky Ricardo yeah and all the
buildings look like pepto-bismol color
yeah there's some of that okay there's
some of that it's just like Miami but a
1950's version Amina Florida or whatever
a Miami Miami
I only know if my Oh Miami looks like
from the grand theft auto vice that's
who
yeah Miami Vice I read that not me my
boy at the resort is better in Mexico
than at the resort in Cuba though that's
a bit but offers or fools by would you
get excited like they eat beans and
plantains I mean that's true yeah that's
there because I had Cuban food Cuban
loot food fire
you have beans and plantains and chicken
there's a bomb Cuban spot called a
Versailles and in Venice Beach Boulevard
it's pretty good yeah interesting
well anyway bring it back to the clip
here do you guys remember when we talked
about a girl a teenage girl who held in
her poop for so long for eight weeks she
barked at house she ended up building up
it build up in her chest cavity and then
it compromised and she eventually died
Oh cuz it pushed her organs and they did
an x-ray and she was full of [ __ ]
so they were saying it's very dangerous
for you to hold your [ __ ] I can't even
hold if I observe him don't you I [ __ ]
on my pants no literally now I feel like
a [ __ ] like like an old man like
we're like a baby now
and I'm saying like literally as soon as
I fish I'm like oh god no stop
everything I need to find it like do can
you [ __ ] outside your house would you
yup now I can't shoot anywhere I should
anywhere Brooklyn when I was like in
junior high I had like [ __ ] anxiety like
I had a [ __ ] at home and I feel like a
lot of people do that like you can't
yeah bank vacation [ __ ] you can't do you
know you can't like [ __ ] your heart out
you know like you got it like you only
[ __ ] a little bit you're constipated
yeah
but then now I'm like I'll [ __ ] on the
floor finding oh I'm the opposite as a
kid on your
I used to have to [ __ ] all the time and
my parents would just let me like go off
the side of the road cuz I was like boom
now you know and then [ __ ] Shane no I
got a hiking trail and I had to poop
like a seriously like at the top like I
always have to like yeah like it's a
long way down to the restroom so they
used to let me go like wherever off
trail and I would [ __ ] everywhere
sometimes I've talked about this before
but locked myself out of the house and I
would have to [ __ ] immediately just that
leg drop in your stomach but now so what
would you know when you like to see us
out of the house I'll go to a bush oh
[ __ ] steep steep don't watch this we
lived in like a community like a complex
community condo complex and so like
there are certain bushes that like you
could go inside of them what did you
wipe um I didn't huh [ __ ] on gos bush I
mean I tried to Bharti Gio's Bush camera
or did Gio's bush yeah now I only [ __ ]
in the toilet up there that was not
intentional yeah I just got it they're
just funny how he said it but then when
you run that up I go you know I was
laughing cuz of that
[Music]
[Music]